I want to shine a light on Armenia and
what's happening so it's been nearly 40
days that the main road to Isaac has
been blocked and that's the main road
that brings in food and medicine and
things like that medical supplies so I
feel like a lot of the diaspora is in a
bit of a you know confused State they
live their life here or you know
anywhere across the world but they want
to help Armenia what's your advice to
them how can we raise our voices how can
we bring shed more light to Armenia I
mean you know so let's process how we
can contribute it's tragic what's going
on over there guys send me a message on
LinkedIn Armenian guy who's a lawyer
over there and saying let me tell you
what's going on I got my dad there I got
my son there I got my sister there I got
my family there here's how many days
they're going without medicine without
this it's it's it's a it is not the
situation to be in right okay
so how can we help one is by talking
about it creating awareness great
two is sending money
great which charity do you trust to send
the money that ends up going to them
biggest criticism when you send money to
sometimes Armenians Assyrians Iranians
you don't know where the money ends up
go okay if it ends up going to them this
is why some of the Charities we were
doing a big charity would raise breast
cancer awareness month and we would do
all Susan G common age that you know 68
of money goes towards you know their
expenses only 32 goes towards research
and all this other and these numbers
that you look at right okay all right
should we not send money no we should
send money should we not talk about it
no we should talk about it but my
interest is a long-term solution not
short-term solution I think when you sit
there and uh Armenia decides to team up
with China which makes sense because
they allow China to come in they allow
Russia to come in and then Russia is in
the middle Putin's trying to sit there
and protect pashinian and Armenia but at
the same time he knows turkey is the
most strongest military in the Middle
East and erdogan is not a lightweight
guy he's a very strong guy and he's got
allies we the U.S in a weird way that
U.S is still very careful with them so
that's the part where strategically
Armenia has to really make an effort
to get tight and get support from
somebody new that's really going to be
defending them that is not a fan of
turkey because Azerbaijan can do
whatever the hell they want to do
because the backend is who turkey so
they're going to come in here and say
yeah no we got we got the you know
they're back and Armenia is going to go
to Putin and Putin's going to say what
well guys try to kind of make it work
and Putin's not going to take a position
if he takes our media's position turkey
is going to say what are you doing if he
takes turkey's position the Armenians in
Russia are going to say what are you
doing so he he becomes way too
diplomatic Putin he's he's in a
interesting spot himself right now while
the world hates him because they don't
know the whole story and is getting
bashed for what's going on with Ukraine
we only know one side of this story
because mainstream media is only telling
us one side we don't know all the
stories it may be true it may not be
true
so it's it's happening at the worst
possible time and this is going to sound
weird if Azerbaijan
ever found a time to really impose
themselves on Armenia this is the time
to do it it's tragic this is the time to
do it because Russia's distracted and
turkey's not this is a very very
important
war and conquering areas and winning is
about timing they have time on their
side if they miss this opportunity
obviously as an Armenian you want them
to not watch this podcast so they miss
this opportunity you want them to not be
thinking this way just to miss the
opportunity but Armenians need to
realize they need to build better
alliances long term that protect them
they don't have the right protection
right now from America I know Nancy
Pelosi went out there and visited but
what happened
who's gone there since what's going on
now what are we expecting now nothing so
short term do whatever you can to get
past this time but why does this keep
repeating and rehashing and re-showing
up that has to do with the political
leaders not making the right decision
the right alliances the right
Partnerships that problem shouldn't show
up you know in life if you keep having
the same health issue because you don't
want to eat or drink or stop smoking and
you keep smoking cigarettes why are you
surprised you have lung cancer I don't
understand why you're surprised nobody
should be surprised if Armenia keeps
trying to build the same alliances with
the same people that don't have their
back fully when an issue like this
happens well apparently they don't
inferior backing if they feel your
backing that would have never happened
so anyways I'm not running for office
I'm not insinuating anything like that
all I'm saying is there needs to be a
leader that they need to sincerely think
about long-term alliances to build
because if they don't
they're not getting any stronger and
here's what's weird about it Armenian
engineers
they're some of the best in the world
right now coders technology the level of
intelligence what they're producing
there it's insane right I can't tell you
how many technology companies are using
Engineers from Armenia because of how
good they are at their work I mean this
this is this is something that doesn't
get highlighted enough but they have the
right to um opportunity to do something
big this is not a call out to pashinian
this is a call out to whoever you vote
next or somebody that's watching this
that actually wants to get involved in
politics
think about long-term Solutions not
short-term you don't have a lot of time
[Music]